served as a gurkha soldier in the
british army for 15 years
his father fought for the country in the
second world war
he's now starving himself outside
downing street
as part of a protest with another
veteran and veterans widow
about how they say they've been treated
we're fighting for
equal rights if there is equal we will
not fight
there is if there is no discrimination
we will not fight
and you've been discriminated against of
course of course
as i told you the pay pension family
permission
everything that is the discrimination
that is against the human right
the two men and one woman all in their
60s
haven't had any food since saturday and
they've been here
sleeping rough just across the street
from the front door
of number 10. gurkhas are nepalese-born
soldiers
known for their bravery they've been
recruited into the british army since
and most recently fought in iraq and the
former yugoslavia
in 2009 actress dorana lumley campaigned
for all veterans who retired before 1997
to be allowed to settle in the uk but
many still
aren't eligible for a full british army
pension
the ministry of defense told sky news we
greatly value the huge contribution
gurkhas make to the british
army and ensure they're supported with a
generous pension
and medical care during retirement in
nepal
we're committed to ensuring the gurkha
pension scheme is sustainable
and fair alongside other uk public
sector
pensions the government says it is going
to increase this pension
and will reveal more soon but time isn't
on mr garung's side
are you prepared to die for this of
course
i sacrificed everything my family
my relatives everybody i sacrifice
that's why i'm here for these gurkhas
the fight goes on
charlotte lomas sky news